lui brut
le flot de la vega bienvenue chez moi on
va faire une petite visite du jardin de
la forêt tiens
il ya trois ans on a arrêté les frérots
les frérots de la vega donc à l'époque
je vivais encore à paris et howell gros
gros changement j'avais envie de me
reconnecter un petit peu un truc plus
essentielles nature mon rapport mois la
nature
j'avais envie d'un petit possible de
comprendre ces écosystèmes et et de
mettre un peu de sens dans mon quotidien
l'expérience rio elle a été formidable
mais elle a amené tellement de lumière
sur moi sur ce côté fait tout le temps
la représentation faut tout le temps en
performant fait tout le temps beau être
tout le temps ci et moi au fond de moi
c'est un truc que j'ai compris
maintenant avec ces trois ans de dermite
c'est qu'en fait moi je suis
profondément les deux je suis un ermite
qui est monté sur scène devant des
milliers de personnes
et ça c'est une dualité une
contradiction est cassée complexe parce
que c'est des choses qui sont vivantes
en moi ça je pensais c'est un petit peu
le l'enjeu de ce de ce nouveau projet de
ce nouvel élan c'est de pouvoir trouve
vraiment l' équilibre et réussir
effectivement à utiliser cette lumière
que l'on m'offre et que j'ai envie
d'honorer mais de l'avenir réellement
sur ce que je suis a de plus authentique
en moi et c'est et c'est tout ça en fait
c'est tout cet univers imagine la taille
de la fougère
2 m
le monde
la loi
tu vois dans le festival que j'aimerais
créer assez comme si j'étais derrière la
scène en fait et les gens ils seraient
directement la ola y aurait ce décor que
j'imagine avec le tipi avec cette espèce
de mur avec tous les électrons et là je
rentrerai sur scène et donc dans ce
décor qui je l'espère un jour sera extra
comestibles et sera voilà tout ce qu'on
te raconter par rapport à l'internât
c'est un truc qui me fait rêver de
l'imaginer de jouer dans un décor
naturel c'est vrai que le monde du
spectacle créé beaucoup de pollution fin
c'est quand on fait des zénith c'est un
truc de fou consomment de l'eau on
consomme de l'essence des gens qui se
déplacent et je pense que c'est très
compliqué de toute façon d'avoir un
équilibre mais je me dis que tu es petit
événement comme ça ça fait des
respirations et c'est important aussi
pour pour inspirer pour pour essayer de
faire quelque chose différemment
donc là on arrive on arrive sur la
partie j'ai commencé à travailler il ya
trois ans et c'était un rectangle
classique de potagers de on a l'habitude
de voir et moi j'ai commencé à planter à
tout ce qui est médicinales tout ce qui
est comestible tout ce qui participe à
la biodiversité et à chaque fois que
j'ai implanté un truc j'y mettais une
plante va manger donc là si on veut on
peut manger des petites framboise ça de
toute façon sera tombé au sol allant
donner ça va revenir dans le sol
certains qu'on amène du bois et la
matière organique en fait on fait que
gradés et on à grade à la fois le sol et
la fois à la fois le coeur parce que
c'est bon pour moi si je trouve ça beau
il ya un mec qui a écrit un livre sur
l'encyclopédie des plantes bio
indicatrices se dire qu'en fait chaque
plante elle poussa un endroit
particulier parce qu'elle a elle a une
un rôle à jouer dira qu est ce qu une
plante une graine germe un endroit c'est
qu'il y avait toutes les conditions
réunies et donc tout ce qui pousse de
manière spontanée quelque part c'est
parce que ça devait se faire de cette
façon et la permaculture et la nature et
la forêt c'est un peu ça qui enseigne
c'est qu'en fait on a toujours tendance
à vouloir contrôler à lutter contre la
nature est en fait si on laisse faire
les choses et qu'on va plutôt dans le
sens de la nature qu'on observe
eh bien on a juste à mettre des petits
voilà tous les intellectuels intellect
de l'humain est ce qu'il sait faire
on a juste à accompagner et accélérer
les choses en fait ici on est donc on
est là sur un lieu isolé n'a pas
l'électricité courante pas l'eau
courante non plus donc c'est grâce à ça
en fait qu on convie ici et qu'on a la
chance d'avoir la lumière le chauffage
le chauffage pas directement mais l'eau
fin tout quoi on est vraiment un coupé
qu'on a les premières les premiers
oiseaux 60 km dans la forêt forêt et
donc ça fait vraiment de chance
incroyable c'est 500 pourrait parler
aussi nous c'était notre rêve d'être en
forêt coin isolé
une fois sur le prix ni la basse hyper
intéressante il a été attaqué par les
pucerons de folie et donc sur le papier
tu dis [ __ ] me fait chier mon arbre il
va mourir et aurait pas de prix ça c'est
la pensée qu'on peut avoir tous ces
essais c'est humain quoi l'image et
planter cet arbre hard et plus sauf que
si tu laisses faire un peu tu observes
que mais finalement ça attire tous les
tous les régulateurs
ça attire les syrphes ces espèces de
petites abeilles qui ressemblent à des
abeilles guêpes qui vont planter qui
vont vous qu'ils vont prendre leurs
larves sont les coccinelles évidemment
qu'ils plantent leurs larves et tu vois
du coup comment ça fonctionne tu vois la
larve de la coccinelle tout petit se
développer en fait cette espèce de
d'alien qui se développe c'est
magnifique et tu la vois bouffer
littéralement tous les pucerons et donc
c'est là aussi tu commences à unir la
dualité en fait on a toujours tendance à
opposer le bon et le mauvais et les
méchants et les bons et en fait dans la
nature il ya aucun méchant il ya aucun
bon n'a qu'une dynamique on a qu un
mouvement perpétuel qui fait que
améliorée et aggraver les choses c'est
vrai que du coup ça cultive la tolérance
parce que si tu es capable dans un
jardin aussi de te mettre dans cette
dynamique d'acceptation
après avec l'être humain aussi tu peux
te mettre dans cette cette philosophie
et je pense que c'est la même chose
c'est ce qui nous dérange chez l'autre
c'est toujours un truc qu'on a en nous
en fait c'est pas l'autre qui nous
dérangeait le reflet de nous et donc le
jardin c'est parfait pour ça c'est un
miroir car pétrole
[Musique]